Once we are happy with our
trained machine learning model,
how can we serve our
predictions at scale?
Find out on this episode
of Cloud AI Adventures.
Google's Cloud Machine
Learning Engine
enables you to
create a prediction
service for your TensorFlow
model without any ops work.
Get more time with your
data by going from a trained
model to a deployed
auto scaling prediction
service in a matter of minutes.
So we've gathered our
data, and finally finished
training up a suitable
model and validating
that it performs well.
So now we're ready to
move to the second phase--
serving those predictions.
When taking on the challenge
of serving predictions,
we would ideally want
to deploy a model that
is purpose-built for serving.
In particular, a fast,
lightweight model
that is static
since we don't need
to do any updating while
serving predictions.
Additionally, if we want
our prediction server
to scale with demand, that adds
another layer of complexity
to the problem.
It turns out that
TensorFlow already
has a built-in
function that can take
care of generating an optimized
model for serving predictions.
It handles all the
adjustments needed,
which saves you a lot of work.
The function that
we're interested in
is called
export_savedmodel, and we
can run it directly from
our classifier object
once we're satisfied with the
state of the trained model.
This will take a
snapshot of your model
and export it as a set of files
that you can use elsewhere.
Over time, as your
model improves,
you can continue to produce
exported models in order
to provide multiple versions.
These exported files are made
up of a file and a folder.
The file is called
saved_model.pb,
which defines the
model structure.
The variables folder
holds two files,
supplying the trained
weights in our model.
Once you have an
exported model, you're
ready to serve it in production.
Here are your two
primary options--
you can use TensorFlow serving
or the Cloud Machine Learning
Engine prediction service.
TensorFlow serving is
a part of TensorFlow,
and available on GitHub.
However, today we will
focus our attention
on Cloud Machine Learning
Engine's prediction service,
though they both have very
similar file interfaces.
Cloud Machine
Learning Engine allows
you to take this exported model
and turn it into a prediction
service with a built-in
endpoint and auto-scaling which
goes all the way down to zero.
It's also complete with a
feature-rich command line
tool, API, and UI.
So we can interact with
it in a number of ways,
depending on our preferences.
Let's see an example of how
to use Cloud Machine Learning
Engine's prediction service
with our Iris sample.
First, we will run
export_savedmodel
on our trained classifier.
This will generate
an exported model
that we can use for
our prediction service.
Next, we'll upload those
files to Google Cloud storage.
Cloud Machine Learning Engine
will read from Cloud storage
when creating a
new model version.
Be sure to choose the
regional storage class,
and to ensure that your compute
and storage in the same region.
In the Cloud Machine
Learning Engine UI,
we can create a new model,
which is really just the wrapper
for our released versions.
Versions hold our
individual exported models
while the model
abstraction helps route
the incoming traffic to
the appropriate version
of your choice.
Here we are in the
models list view
where we can create a new model
All it takes to create a model
is to just give it a name.
Let's call it ours Iris Model.
Next, we'll create a
version by choosing
a name for this
particular model version
and pointing it to our
Cloud storage directory that
holds our exported files.
And just like that,
we've created our model.
All it took was pointing the
service at our exported model
and giving it a name.
How could it take
so little work?
Well, the service handled
all the operational aspects
of setting up and
securing the endpoint.
Moreover, we didn't need to
write our own code for scaling
it out based on demand.
And since this is the
Cloud, this elasticity
means you don't need to
pay for unused compute
when demand is low.
By setting up a prediction
service for our Iris Model
that didn't need
any ops work, we've
been able to go
from trained model
to deployed auto-scaling
prediction service
in a matter of minutes, which
means more time to get back
to working with your data.
Thanks for watching this
episode of Cloud AI Adventures.
Be sure to subscribe to the
channel to catch all the latest
episodes as they come out.
Also, check out the links at
the bottom for a cool talk
from the TensorFlow team.
And don't forget, when it
comes to scaling your machine
learning service in production,
Cloud Machine Learning Engine's
got your back.
Thanks for watching that
episode of Cloud AI Adventures.
You can catch the
whole series here.
And if you have any
thoughts and comments,
feel free to leave
them down below.